[Music]
yeah hopefully not playing a cheater
this time
omega chilling 1886.
all right let's go e4 c5 and
another smith moore that's how the last
game started
let's hope
the result here will be a little bit
different
c3
okay another accepted smith mora
okay so mark told me that
you basically want to go knight f3
before bishop c4 in most of these
positions
so
we want to start by developing our
knights then we put the bishop on c4 and
the movie six is very very topical it's
one of the main moves in the position
and it's you know black has not decided
on a particular setup yet
right we basically need to wait for
black to show their cards the way to do
that is to develop as flexibly as
possible with a move like knight f3
okay so we play knight f3 now there's a
bunch of moves that black has a6 bishop
b4 i know is a move black can play d6
and transpose back into the the main
line okay so a6
now this is a position which we've
discussed on several occasions because
the correct move here as far as i
remember
is
one that you wouldn't necessarily be
inclined to play if you aren't
experienced in this position
so if you aren't experienced in this
position i think a lot of you might be
tempted to go bishop f4
and say well let's try to put the bishop
on d6
right and occupy that weak square the
problem with bishop f4
as far as i know is that black goes d6
and then the bishop is a little bit
awkward on f4 it could potentially walk
into the move e5 with tempo
so
despite
principles you actually want to go
bishop c4 here
now again
why are we biting on granite right this
looks like the least appetizing square
for the bishop but
if you've watched my previous speed runs
you might remember that there was a
smith warrior game in which we had this
line
and i don't know this line too well
myself so disclaimer i might mess up the
theory
but
essentially the point of bishop c4 is to
prepare a night sacrifice a little bit
further down the road
and that night sacrifice
is knight c3 to d5
and you can kind of visualize the
scenario where that knight sacrifice is
very strong once we castle and
especially if we put a rook on e1
putting a knight on d5 is basically what
makes this position tick
so that bishop in a way supports
the knight that will later go to d5 in
most lines
the other thing to realize is that
a lot later down the line once black
castles we don't have to stick to c4
and we can reposition the bishop to
the b1 h7 diagonal later on down the
line bishop e7 okay bishop b7 i don't
really know
this doesn't look like a particularly
independent move because black is
probably going to end up developing one
of his knights
on the next move
so it's way too early for knight d5
right we haven't developed any of our
pieces yet so sacrificing here makes
absolutely no s actually it makes a
little bit of sense
or maybe it does make some sense knight
t5 he takes d5 we have queen takes d5
threatening checkmate on f7
and it's very hard for black to stop
that threat
so 1995 is believe it or not quite
interesting but i think
it's not really in the spirit of the
position and i think we should prepare
it by castling
i think we should prepare it by castling
i think we should uh we should be
patient
because remember after knight d5 black
does not have to take that knight okay
so black has played d6 which is is
essentially a transposition into a line
that i'm a little bit more familiar with
now you might remember
from the previous game in which we faced
the cheater but still
what is the proper configuration in this
position how should we proceed
and if you don't know this particular
setup then it's hard to play this
position properly
essentially you need to switch places
the queen the queen spot is prime real
estate
it's absolute prime real estate because
black's queen on d8 doesn't have a clear
place to go
and so what you need to do here is move
the queen out of the way
and you want to keep it centralized
right you don't want to move it to like
b3
you want to keep it centralized and you
want to make sure that it's protecting
the bishop
and then you want to reposition the rook
from f1 to d1
in order to x-ray black's queen and put
pressure on the weak d6 pawn that's kind
of the logic behind the setup
now a lot of you are like but wait a
minute isn't b5 an annoying idea here
don't we want to play a4 in such
positions to prevent b5 well remember
that when you sacrifice a pawn the role
that time plays is generally a lot more
central you don't have time to waste on
positional niceties
and in this case b5 is not scary it may
look annoying but you just drop your
bishop back to b3
don't be fooled by moves that create one
move threat you just move back to b3 and
the quote-unquote initiative is over
the other problem with a4 is that it
creates a hole on b4
which black could later potentially
occupy with a knight for instance but
also not a big deal but not something
you want to do voluntary
okay so knight d7 i'm not familiar with
i'm only familiar with
knight b8 to c6
i don't think we have to vary our play
against knight d7 i think we can
continue
in exactly the same way that we would
normally continue so
i think we should go rook d1
and position our rook
on the best possible square and put
pressure on d6 queen c7 okay
so this is somewhat passive play by our
opponent i don't think black is doing
anything terribly wrong but i think he's
getting himself into a very dubious
position
so
we have not completed our development
and we need to figure out
where we want our bishop where do we
want our bishop
well as many of you are indicating you
want the bishop on f4
why do you want the bishop on f4 doesn't
it walk into e5
well because black is so passive the
move e5
comes with a very very hefty price tag
right e5 creates a gaping hole on d5 and
especially since blackboard is queen on
c7
knight d5 will actually come with tempo
so we want to play bishop f4 in order to
put more pressure on d6 and we actually
want to provoke black into playing e5
so that the diagonal for our other
bishop is opened and so that we get this
massive outpost on d5 now we could have
also played bishop e3 there wasn't
anything specifically wrong with that
move i think bishop b3 was also quite
decent but bishop f4 has a lot more
pizzazz to it okay so knight f6 knight
gf6
how should we continue ladies and
gentlemen
well we should continue
putting pieces on good squares now
i know a lot of you are very tempted by
the movie five
but e5 is the kind of move that might
look very very good
but you have to calculate it you can't
just play a move like that and expect
that it works what happens if we play e5
well if we play e5
black will take on e5
white will recapture with the pawn
black will play knight takes c5 we take
with the bishop and then black moves his
queen up to a5 for example so we don't
actually accomplish as much as it seems
with the movie five we need to prepare
it and we need to prepare it by bringing
all of our pieces into the game
we need to prepare it by bringing all of
our pieces into the game rook a1 to c1
is very natural because we create an
x-ray against his queen
but maybe e5 is good i i don't really
know the theory that well myself so
maybe e5 is very very strong we'll have
to investigate after the game
so i'm anticipating black castling
and then already e5 looks quite a bit
stronger than it did on the previous
move happy bisho you're asking bishop
takes d6 but that blunder's a bishop
just bishop takes d6 black defends that
square twice and we're attacking it
twice so we can't take so a lot depends
on how black plays in this position our
opponent is settling into a think
apart from e5
which kind of blasts open the center and
we've been discussing
okay never mind you see black plays a
move and that completely changes the
landscape
of the position
and
just intuitively it seems to me that
black really cannot get away with this
move
what is the drawback of the movie five
well we've already discussed it right it
opens up the diagonal for the bishop
and it also creates a big big hole on d5
but we need to be very careful how we
respond to a move like that because i
think a lot of players here fall for
something very very tempting without
really calculating it
so one option that many of you are
pointing out is a sacrifice right we can
play bishop takes f7 check that comes to
mind
and the idea is to drive the king out
into the open and also to potentially
exploit a discovered attack against
black screen so let's try to estimate
how that line could potentially go
so let's say we play bishop takes f7
king takes f7
well
how could we continue in that position
how could we continue in that position
could could we try to exploit perhaps
the discovery against the black queen
yeah we could throw in a check on g5 but
i would also argue that that check on g5
isn't going anywhere we don't have to
give it immediately
so what i like to do what i would like
to do is to go takes takes
and then to throw a knight onto d5
that attacks the queen from two
different sources
and if the queen moves away so bishop f7
king f7 knight d5 the queen is attacked
by the rook and it's also attacked by
the knight
so let's say the queen moves back to d8
in that position
then i think we give a check on g5
and then if the king moves back to e8
we have a knight on d5 we have a rook on
c1 what are both of these pieces aiming
at we enter c7 with a fork
and that looks completely crushing
and that looks completely crushing
now
there is one very high level detail that
i haven't mentioned yet
and
is it a deal breaker not completely and
we're gonna go for this sacrifice anyway
but i'm gonna leave it unmentioned and i
wonder if you guys will be able to find
it
after we play knight t5 there is a
resource after knight d5 that i have not
mentioned
and this resource worries me a little
bit not enough for me for me not to go
into this line but
it's something that i would very
seriously consider if i had black
yeah so as many of you
are pointing out
it's 95 and then knight takes d5 in
order to get as many pieces as possible
for the queen the 95 knight takes d5
rook takes queen and then that knight
from d5 takes the rook so what does
black get for the queen black gets a
rook and two minor pieces which is a lot
and normally that would be an immediate
deal breaker but remember that we've
also driven the king out onto a super
vulnerable square and black's pieces are
terribly terribly positioned so that
complicates the story and i think we'll
still be able to use the queen there to
get an advantage
so intuitively i feel like that line is
still worth going for even if black gets
a material advantage formally
so i hope i hope the logic makes sense
bishop takes f7 is extremely thematic
it's one of those sacrifices that if you
if you've played this opening
any amount of times you should be aware
that this is an idea that exists
would i sack in an over the board game
well i'll point on that question by
saying that i
would take a lot longer to consider a
sack like this i probably would but i
would take a lot longer to consider this
move and to consider the follow-up
and many times you know we could have
also just dropped our bishop back to e3
there would have been nothing wrong with
just a more measured approach and we
would have gotten what we wanted out of
the position we would have had the d5
square in a fantastic position great
compensation but
this is the chance that will not present
itself again
because on the next move black would
have almost certainly castled and then
we would have had to slow roll the
position so
this is the kind of move that you should
play now or never
so i have an interesting observation
which is that after king takes f7 i've
been reflecting on that position and i
don't really know what black is thinking
about it's not like king f8 is possible
here
so after king takes f7 i'm actually
starting to think
that knight g5 check is a better move
than knight d5
yeah so renko again but at the end of
that line black has 96.
so king takes f7 knight d5 knight takes
d5 is what we're calculating
rook takes queen
knight takes rook and then some of you
are noticing that there's a knight on c7
and a king on f7
queen c4 check forks the knight and the
king but when you fork a knight you have
to be especially careful that that same
knight cannot move in and block the
check and in that final position what
move does black have
yeah 96 black has knight c7 to e6
covering the check
and it looks like black is holding
everything together and i'll show all of
these lines after the game so if you're
not following don't worry don't exit out
of the stream
i'll show everything over the board
after the game
right now it's just that i can't move
pieces so i have to do stuff we have to
do stuff in our head
but back to what i was saying king takes
f7 i actually like the idea of giving a
check on g5
and then once the king drops back to e8
we have an option
in addition
to playing knight d5 we don't actually
have to play knight d5 what is an
alternative in that position
so we actually have at least two
alternatives we have 96 which many of
you are pointing out we can worm our way
into e6 and we're also forking the queen
and the g7 pawn but
we have another very interesting option
we have the option of going knight b5
not knight d5 but knight b5
and the great thing about knight b5 is
that black doesn't have the same
idea as he does after knight d5 right
after knight d5 black can take on d5 and
then take the the rook with that knight
but after knight b5 black can't even get
the same amount of material for the
queen okay he kind of can
but not in the same way
and the great thing about knight b5 is
that we are still going for c7
so we we will still be able to access
the promised land if the queen moves
away
but this time without allowing the extra
option of black sacrificing for the
queen notice how much thinking i've
already done here king takes f7 finally
and i think we can very safely go for
that option so let's begin
with the move
let's begin
with the move knight g5 check forcing
the king to decide where it wants to go
forcing the king to decide where it
wants to go
now some of you are like well what about
king f8 well king f8 walks into a fork
knight e6 check king e8 quickly and this
is a critical moment so now knight d5 is
really really bad because after knight
takes d5
rook takes queen knight takes rook the
king on e8 is quite safe
if we had wanted to go for that line we
should have done so
on the previous move we should have kept
the king on f7
but to reiterate the main point that i
noticed here we don't have to go knight
d5 we have another way of achieving the
same idea without the drawbacks and that
is knight c3 to b5
again we hit the queen from two
different directions it's a double
attack on the queen
which means that the only way for black
to save the queen is to move it just
like if there was a king on c7 it's the
same principle right
so
black kim
if he wants
give up the queen for a rook and a piece
and black is already up a piece so that
would make it a rook and two minor
pieces queen takes c1
but after queen takes c1
don't rush to assume that you have to
recapture the queen i think the key
insight that i made is i noticed that we
have an intermediate move after queen
takes e1 that changes everything
this knight is already going to be lost
so we might as well give it up for the
maximum amount of material knight takes
d6 check
okay bishop takes d6
and then what do you recapture the queen
with the rook or the bishop
in that resulting position
you take with the bishop you take with
the bishop because remember the bishop
is hanging you take with the bishop and
how do we evaluate the resulting
position well what we've done
by playing knight takes d6 check is not
only one upon right we've won a pawn
which is great but we have opened up the
d file and in a position like this where
black is as passive as he is
opening up files is the difference
between
consolidation and a crushing attack and
there it is we go down that line
so not bishop takes c1 which allows
black to take on b5 and keep his center
intact
making the king a lot safer we start by
taking on d6 with check
now bishop takes d6 is force because
like why would black not take it if he
has the chance to take it
well we have an extra queen but black
has a rook in two minor pieces so
technically black is up material here
not a lot but some but i think we're
completely winning
i think we're completely winning bishop
takes queen again
why not rook takes queen because that
would have just hung the bishop on f4
which is now hanging
and we get this position how do i know
that we're winning well i know that
we're winning because we have several
ideas that i think black has no answer
to what are these ideas
and after king e7 i think we can execute
one of them which essentially just wins
the game on the spot so what i'm
noticing here
is that our main attacker is the knight
right our knight seems to be
our biggest asset our rook is also a
huge asset
so some of you might notice the idea of
taking on d6
and playing knight f7 check and then
knight takes h8 and that would win a
piece
the drawback of that continuation is
that we would essentially be cashing in
our attack for an extra piece that's
completely winning
but maybe the knight could conceivably
get trapped in that final position and
that's a little bit messy so let's see
if we can find something a little bit
cleaner what is the knight exactly doing
well the knight on its own is not really
ready
to move into any of these squares but
perhaps we could use the queen for
assistance
how could we do that well as many of you
are pointing out queen c4 i think is
just absolutely crushing because you are
creating essentially a double attack
you're threatening queenie six check and
you're threatening queen f7 check which
is incidentally a mate threat queen f7
check and then knight e6 is literally
checkmate
and i've quickly determined that black
has no way
to defend both of these squares at the
same time
black can defend each one of them on
their own like rook f8
but then we'd give a check on e6 or if
black moves the knight away to defend e6
then we play queen f7 and also
when we play queen f7 the king has to
move back and if necessary we could
simply take the bishop on d6 and we'd be
totally winning
and the game is over that's how quickly
the attack happens and and crushes
but there was a lot that was involved in
in finding these moves
there was a lot that was involved in not
going down the wrong line and i think
when you look at games like this
like these and queen f7 check of course
not not queen e6 because blacks defended
that square but now we play queen f7 and
then we take on d6 and the game is over
when you look at games like these you
think well the attack was very
straightforward that was super simple
not much happened but hopefully you're
able to see now that behind the scenes
there's a ton of calculation that has to
happen and you
the hardest thing is to actually reject
the wrong lines the lines that look
tempting but allow a particular defense
but the game is not over let's finish
this off
so
what is the most effect effective and
efficient way of ending the game
so you can essentially take two
approaches in a position like this the
first approach is just to take a bunch
of pieces
the first approach is just to play queen
takes g7
and hit the rook on the night and then
you win the night and you win the game
the second approach is to aim for
checkmate and to try to use your
remaining pieces and this is the
approach that i usually prefer so
there's a very calm move
and how do i find this move well
i find this move because i know that we
still have a piece that is not in the
game our bishop on c1 is still dormant
and the move that comes to mind is
bishop e3 a lot of you are proposing 96
check i don't like that move
it's fancy
and you're you're attracted to it
because you're using the pin
but ask yourself what it actually
achieves 96 check knight takes e6 queen
takes c6 do you even have a threat there
yeah i understand that you your opponent
can't take your queen and you feel cool
but you don't have a threat
and you're trading in your main attacker
for
nebulous reasons
so advantage of bishop e3 over bishop d2
well it's the fact that we're actually
attacking the knight
bishop e3 creates a threat bishop d2
doesn't
so we're simply threatening to take the
knight and we're also keeping all of our
pieces on their prime attacking
locations
pawn b4 would have worked but it
wouldn't have brought the bishop into
the game so
i like this move even more than before
again we're completely winning and
you shouldn't look at this and say oh i
didn't see bishop e3 i suck at attacking
a gazillion different moves win and i
would recommend most people to just play
queen takes g7 i would recommend most
people just to take queen takes g7 to
take the knight and end the game but
i want to try to be as precise as
possible
because that's the
philosophy behind the speed run
is i don't i don't shy away from making
moves that i'd be making over the board
just because they're a little bit more
complicated
and again notice how
i'm always defaulting
to involving as many pieces as possible
in the attack
right a move that activates a piece and
brings it into the game is rarely going
to be bad in any position
so it's just something that you can
default to if you're not sure what to do
h6 that's a good move
that's a good move and i think we're
unfortunately going to have to oh
actually no i see a mate
i see a mate
in a very night nice mate actually
so let's start by taking the knight
let's start by taking the knight and
eliminating it moving it off the board
so after h takes g5
who can spot the mating sequence
there's a very very nice mating sequence
it starts with a check
it starts with a check it starts with a
move that i know all of you are saying
which is bishop b6 check
and how do i see this well the reason i
see this is because i noticed that a
queen could land on c7 and that is
checkmate if a queen lands on c7 that's
made so what move comes to mind
well how can the queen get to c7 well
can get to c7 via c4 but after queen c4
black can block the check with the
bishop hopefully you noticed that as
well bishop c6 but if you understand
what you're aiming for then the move
should be very easy after that queen c4
check bishop c6 you just play rook takes
c6 check you break through
bc queen takes c6 check king b8 and then
queen c7 is checkmate you identify the
target square and then you chart the
course to that square when c4 check is
over
very straightforward logic and solving a
ton of exercises is going to help you
find these mates quickly and efficiently
and
here's another interesting point it's
not like i
saw something
specific that allowed me to see queen c4
i'm breaking this down for you
logically but that's not how i found the
move i found it the move just occurred
to me
the move just occurred to me sort of
automatically
because it's it's just pattern
recognition right it's just complete
pattern recognition
queen c4 queen c7 i maybe seen this idea
a gazillion times
and it's it's almost like your
multiplication tables
and that's something you have to
understand which is that
if you solve a certain amount of
exercises and at a certain experience
level you'll just start seeing
ideas like this automatically even if it
seems right now that you're never going
to reach that point you have to trust
that you'll get to a point where you
will see this stuff
super super quickly and that's what
makes chess training
sometimes such a thankless task is you
don't even really know
what you're aiming for you don't really
see results immediately
but you have to trust that eventually
this is going to create an impact
okay um
so let's see
yeah that was a nice game i'm gonna
check mark's book
to make sure that we played correctly
all right we got it loot secured
so this is mark esterman's book on the
on the smith mora which i highly
recommend it's called mayhem in the mora
e6 knight f3 is correct
then a6
let's see if that's analyzed so
it is analyzed e6 and a6 we correctly
played bishop c4
and then i think mark does not look at
the move bishop e7 but
what he does look at
is d6 castles
and knight c6 which is a line but
putting the bishop on e7 first is really
really weird like bishop e7 is just
passive that was a step in the wrong
direction
and then after d6
we play our typical configuration we
play queen e2
now the important thing to understand
about this position is that if black
plays knight c6
then it kind of transposes to a pretty
well-known line
here you play rook d1 and this reaches a
theoretical position which mark analyzes
in his book but the move knight d7
there are no games in the database this
is a very very strange move and this is
a strange move because it
it it's just passive right developing
the knight to d7 is very very passive
and it
it increases the effectiveness of rook
d1 so i see four games in the database
at this point
and queen c7 i think is is is another
mistake
knight gf6 is how the four games
continued
and now two games went e5
d e5 knight takes e5 and you can just
see
the amount of pressure that you're
putting on black's position here
so anyways
black plays queen c7 we play bishop f4
oh and interestingly in this position
there are 20 games in the database so
perhaps we clearly
transposed to some sort of a line
and all 20 games continued knight e5
oh apparently this is this is a line
apparently this is a line knight e5
bishop takes c5 de5 rook ac1 still looks
really really good for this position
just looks really really really good for
white
this position just looks really really
good for white knight e5 bishop p5d five
rook ac one queen b8
oh and then bishop b5 check has been
played
oh maria did commentary for nemo and
then you got this position in two games
and this is just
freaking
awesome
this is just awesome f6 knight c7
you have seven knight a queen a8 rook c7
and this is just uh
totally and absolutely crushing
just curious what game this was tori
against testage from 1974
damn girl 1974.
so this line has been around for a very
long time
two 2200s and white crushed crushed to
crush them in this game
okay so knight gf6
now we play rook ac1 everything i did
here should be obvious and what i'm
really curious about
is whether bishop takes f7 is the top
engine move
let's
test it out is bishop takes f7
the top engine move
let's see i i doubt that it is but i
also wouldn't rule it out i feel like
it's so so powerful
okay it
is the second move and the the top move
is a version of it oh we just had knight
b5
knight b5 is very very strong here oh
and look at this this is sick if queen
b8 okay if a takes b5 you play bishop
takes f7 check and then you win the
queen right that's easy
that's easy but if queen b8 this is what
i missed we have knight c7 check anyway
and i've seen this concept before
dragging the queen back to c7 and then
we played bishop f7 again and if black
moves the king
oh my god then the top move is bishop
takes f7 here but this is a much much
better version of the sacrifice than we
had this is like what what i did except
we have a knight freaking already on c7
but this isn't even close queen c4 check
and knight g5 and it's crushing so that
was a cool idea we had knight b5 first
and then knight c7 and then bishop takes
f7 so
we took immediately which is good but
not as convincing
and the reason it's not as convincing
knight g5 is correct
and the reason it's not as convincing is
because of king g6 which i saw
oh and the idea that we discussed knight
d5
so if the queen moves then black loses
but black has this knight takes d5
resource that i was talking about during
the game oh my god and look at this
white's top move is not rook takes queen
it's 96
what a move 96
so you're attacking the queen from a
second source
and if the queen drops back then you get
checkmated after queen g4 oh my god you
suck a third piece
king f7
queen takes g7
ed5 king f5 and this is checkmate
because the king is way too exposed
simply beautiful
for example bishop f6g oh my god oh my
god look at this mate
king e4 the maiden 2 is king g2
oh my god that's amazing bishop g7 f3 is
checkmate
holy smokes and look at what the second
best move is queen takes h7
oh my god this is still made oh and you
sacked the bishop too
oh my god look at this mate you're down
a queen in three pieces
i mean this is why the mora is such an
amazing opening like these are the kinds
of ideas that you get
this is like freaking amazing you can
even check me without the bishop
imagine if we had this yeah that would
have been insane and you can also mate
with the move g4 check sack the bishop
but this is all very easy i mean you
should understand why this is made just
because the king is so wide open look at
black's pieces
black is nothing in the defense so this
this should not be surprising that these
lines exist e4 rookie 4 i mean there's
sacrifices everywhere
so
that's incredible
and that means 96 is the only way to
gain an advantage here according to the
engine if you take the queen hastily
then after knight c7 the position is
completely unclear it's equal
in fact white has to be careful because
white's got both minor pieces are
hanging
incredible incredible lines king g6
would have been the most resilient move
for black so our opponent played king e8
and now we correctly found knight b5
okay so according to the engine oh we
still had this idea knight takes d596 i
mean i
this move was like
completely not on my radar 96 not taking
the queen
okay so let's say queen b6 what's the
idea here oh it's knight g7
king f7 if king d8 by the way there's a
check made in two moves check
and mate which is kind of nice
so king f7 we sack another piece with
queen h5
bishop h6 check oh and here the attack
is pretty pedestrian we play rook d3 and
lift the rook up to g3
knight f4 rook g3 knight g6 rook g6 is
the classic
hg queen g6 is checkmate
incredible i mean sax everywhere
so many attackers
so i played knight b5 which is good
queen c1 and now look at the engine only
move knight takes d6 check rook c1 was
an advantage but not nearly as
convincing so this is the secret sauce
knight takes d6 check and then bishop
takes c1 and it's plus two it's actually
not as winning as i thought it would be
but the only move to keep it at plus two
is h6 which is a really hard move to
play
because it looks like it actually forces
the knight onto a square that we want to
go to anyway
but very computer-ish idea king e7
you give up g7 and then you go knight c5
to control the f5 square with the bishop
so that knight f5 check you can take on
f5 so black holds on in this position
and black can defend but for a human i
think it's impossible
okay so once our opponent played king e7
the game is over queen c4
and look at how much better queen c4 is
than rook takes d6 it's not even close
because queen c4 goes for checkmate
knight c5 queen f7 checking the eight
and now it's plus 12.
okay so bishop e3 is is good queen takes
g7 is technically the top move but
bishop b3 is also very good
h6 and now bishop c5 is correct
check
okay rook f6
is made in five takes
wow queen d5 simply look at this and
then queen d6 and queen c7 is
unstoppable black literally you can
literally pre-move those moves
basically
but we went made in five which is good
enough because if king king b8 would
have staved it off a little bit longer
but who cares who cares
and then it's made what does the
computer say about 96 check when
i'm not sure when you're talking about
wow
and that's the game ladies and gentlemen
but i want you to notice something which
is that look at how much prop how many
problems were caused
by the fact that our opponent developed
the knight to d7 rather than c6 if the
knight had been on c6 none of this would
have worked there wouldn't have been the
c file x-ray
and most importantly the e6 square would
have been protected by the bishop so
tons of problems stemmed from the fact
that this knight on d7 was interfering
with black's entire construction
so can the engine save black position
yeah i don't think i would beat the
engine from this position i don't think
magnus
okay with magnus it would probably be 50
50. the the engine can basically save
any position that is probably plus two
and below the engine will probably save
this position against me in like a
classical game
but it doesn't matter you you have to
evaluate positions based on
human understanding
and this line is simply incredible king
g6 so you start with knight d5
this is understandable but after knight
takes d5 i think the highlight of this
analysis is knight e6 that's just such a
sexy move you don't take the queen
and instead you go for checkmate you
prepare queen g4 check
knight f4 by the way oh knight f4 you
just play knight takes f4 and then
and then rook takes c7 with
overwhelming position
oh my god
any questions
well the the browser engine is weak but
it's good enough right it gives us a
pretty decent perspective on what the
ballpark evaluation is we're not looking
here for a scientific evaluation we're
looking for a ballpark estimate of what
the eval is and for that like depth 20
is perfectly sufficient we we don't need
like a super computer
you understand what i'm saying
well i explain why it's only plus two
plus two is a lot plus two is basically
borderline winning
but the reason it's quote unquote only
plus two is because black gets a ton of
pieces for the queen
and there is no forced checkmate
so
after 95 95 96 black has this defensive
move knight c5
which is a really really nice move
and if knight takes queen
then black takes on f4 and attacks
white's queen bishop defends g4 so you
don't have that check and black has
three pieces for the queen so
knight c5 is not a move that i think
most
humans would even think about
but it's the only way to get a
reasonable play and notice how white's
best move here isn't even to take the
queen it's queen g4
queen takes g7 giving up the knight and
then going for this position
ef4 black has three pieces for a rook
but you're going to win one of them back
and the king is just totally busted here
so
well
oxinia
i would qualify that statement plus two
is not nothing under 1500 it depends on
what kind of plus two it is if you have
a kind of plus two that's an extra piece
and an end game
then i i would say it's pretty safe but
a position like this
of course is still anyone's game like
under 1500 because it's so chaotic that
you can expect a lot of mistakes among
uh you know beginner to intermediate
players but
how much stronger is chess space's
engine compared to browserfish so
there's something you have to understand
which is that the engines themselves are
not different on chess space and on
chess.com it's the speed that's
different it's the speed at which it
reaches a higher depth
now at the same depth this stock fish
and the chess-based stock fish give the
same thing it's just that it just took
this stockfish maybe three minutes to
reach depth 28 and if i load it on chess
base it uses more resources so it'll
reach step 28 maybe in 15 seconds so
it's just much more efficient to analyze
with the chest space stock fish because
it reaches a higher depth much faster
and you're able to access and get to a
lot more positions at a higher depth
so
the dictionary definition of plus two is
like two puns up
that's that's the equivalent of two puns
up but clearly in this position black
white is not two pawns up
plus two can also signify
an advantage that comes from other
sources such as a decisive attack or
a more positional advantage you cannot
always quantify exactly why
a certain evaluation is what it is if it
was as easy as that then chess would not
be a difficult game
in many cases you look at a position
even gm looks at a position and says i
don't understand why this is plus four
sometimes i don't even understand why
something is like plus seven
you know in extreme cases but the
reasoning could be very subtle
like oh there's some sort of threat and
that threat is unstoppable but you don't
know what that threat is until you
analyze the position so
evals can be easy to understand if
you're up a piece and you see that it's
plus five you're like well it's because
you're up a piece sometimes evals are a
lot harder to understand and it's a good
practice to try to figure out why the
engine eval is what it is and try to
verbalize and analyze until you figure
it out
winning an exchange again but you can't
take that in a vacuum because what if
it's an exchange sacrifice for full
compensation
yeah winning an exchange without
compensation in most cases
you could probably peg that at
approximately plus two plus 2.5
but it completely depends on
like
the context like is it a middle game is
it if you wouldn't exchange in an end
game it could be plus ten
okay we can do more questions i'm i'm
enjoying this
yeah and that's another thing that i i
want people to understand sometimes you
bring up a great point you could have a
position that's plus
11 or plus seven
but the reason that it's plus seven is
not because you're up a queen it's
because you have a forced sequence
and this sequence results in a checkmate
or results in a winning position but if
you don't find the sequence then the
next best move is let's say equality
right and a lot of times people get
really mad at themselves like why it was
plus 11. well that's a meaningless
statement it's not that you were plus 11
it's just that you had a win and you
didn't find the win and
you know if you didn't find the win then
the second best move led to equality
what is this seven eight to ninety six
with a five subs let's go
thank you
i mean i can give you an example of that
i can give you many examples of that
from my my career examples of positions
in which
if you don't find the best move
then the evaluation drops
precipitously
to
you know
to whatever it is here's a good example
i i have something in mind
no it feels terrible to miss to miss a
win that's one of the worst feelings in
chat so here's a great example
a position that i that i bought which is
plus 13.
okay so this position ladies and
gentlemen
this is from one of my games in 2012.
now this was a big game if i had won
this game i would have been in a great
position for a gm norm you can notice
that i lost i i lost in the end so it's
white to play
and
i will spare you the i won't i won't
necessarily treat this as an exercise
i'll just show you what happens so so
basically i'm winning in in
in one move
the winning line here but there is only
one winning line
and the winning line is to play bishop
takes f5
so you start by taking the knight
and the reason that you want to take the
knight is the knight was defending the
g3 square
and why is that important that the
knight was defending the g3 score
because you can play the move rook g3
now thank you david cosmar gifting a sub
why is rick g3 so overwhelming well
because it threatens checkmate on g8
why is that dangerous because black
cannot defend against it black's pieces
are way too discombobulated
the only thing black can try is to put a
piece in the middle of the rook and the
queen
so black can try knight g5
but now what should white do what is the
fastest path to checkmate here
the only piece that can defend yeah
exactly exactly
so you move the bishop but what do you
do with it i mean the simplest is bishop
takes g5 you just take that you just
take the knight you take the knight
thank you valor may with the two subs
f takes g5 and back to h3 you go
and you deliver ladder checkmate rook h7
rook takes h7 mate
so you use the g file and then you
transition back to the h file after
black plays knight g5
but let's turn on the engine and see
what's going on it might seem in a
position like this that there are like
four or five
different winning sequences and that's
kind of what i thought i thought uh you
know
anything is winning
and i played
a move within like a minute
but if you actually look at the
stockfish eval let me uh
resize this a little bit so you can see
notice that bishop takes f5 is literally
like plus 15. it's basically checkmate
but if we add a line
the second best move
is some ridiculous bishop e3 move that
equalizes and if we add another line
the third best move
is going to be winning for black
and that is the move that i played i
played the terrible e takes f6
my thinking was that i was preparing
bishop g7 check which i thought was
mating
and i completely missed queen takes b2
why is that even a defense because after
bishop g7 check which i played
black plays rook takes g7 and i forgot
that the queen was actually defending
the g7 square f takes g7 and queen takes
g7 defends against all of the threats
and it forces a queen trade to make
matters worse because the rook in the
corner is hanging so white has to trade
queens and black is winning in this end
game because he's got two pieces for a
rook and a huge pawn center etc and
black ended up winning
why not rook takes h7 i don't at which
point could you have played rook h7
yeah they had us playing on christmas
that was well this is like a christmas
and new year's tournament
yeah well g4
g4 doesn't quite work because of knight
g5
sadly
that doesn't work out yeah rook h7 and
g4 is interesting
but black has this move rook c3
and after rook d1
black moves the king away
gf and bishop h5 remember the black is
basically also
you know rook d2 e5
and this end game is just winning for
black it's not the material that matters
it's the fact that black has these
connected passers and white's position
is in shambles so
nothing can save white in this position
my opponent ended up mating me with
knight and bishop which is kind of funny
yeah i've shown this position before but
in a different context
so
i lost a lot of sleep that night
especially when i realized that i missed
i realized that i missed this win on the
way home i didn't even check with the
engine i literally was thinking about
the game and i was like i must have
missed a mate somewhere and then i
immediately it just occurred to me i
could have taken an f5 and done rook g3
it's one of the most infuriating
sensations because you were literally
that close one move in the game would
have been in would have been over
but that's just life like you've got to
accept that as part of your your chess
journey you're going to have games like
that and uh there's just not much you
can do about it you're going to you're
going to screw things up but the reason
i was showing this in the first place is
to demonstrate an example
of you could tell your friend oh i was
plus 13
and i didn't win
but that would be disingenuous it was
less that and more that you just had one
win and if you didn't find it you were
basically lost right black is better
after g takes f6 yeah that move doesn't
just relinquish the win it actually
gives black a winning position yeah so
that's another thing a great point
in many cases it's plus 11
but you found you find a line which
simplifies to a position that you know
is very easy to win but the engine
doesn't think in terms of what's easier
to win the engine thinks very
materialistically so sometimes you give
up let's say a queen for a rook to
simplify to a position where you just
have a rook and then the engine says
that's a blunder and you understand that
you have to take such things with a
grain of salt it doesn't mean it's
actually a blunder in human terms it
might just be the most prudent option
even if according to the engine it
brought the evaluation down because for
example you gave up some material
so you just have to use your common
sense
rather than just looking at what the
engine says and just automatically
assuming that whatever the engine says
is
biblical knowledge sometimes you
actually can be smarter than the engine
especially in the event of like
a line which simplifies to a much easier
position to win
yeah i know people don't have common
sense these days but
you know you can still use it in chess
okay guys i think i'm gonna call it a
night i'm getting tired today has been a
very good day
[Music]